you know i've seen a lot of interviews
with you and uh
all the people that you've worked with
and i know what comes into my mind is do
you ever get starstruck i see you like
there's a shot on the comeback trail
with like de niro behind the camera
giving you the offline you know
off-camera lines to you
and i'm thinking that's got to be the
most surreal thing i know you're
probably used to it
well do you get used to it and do you
ever feel like god i sucked in front of
one of the greats i'm sucking
i'm sucking i can't get it i'm getting
nervous i don't really i don't think i
get that used to it
i remember like my first day on comeback
trail with de niro i was already really
prepared because it was
a scene with just lots of lines just
rattling him off non-stop but i was
still so nervous
and then he and then we started the
scene and he was just like came
guns blazing like just
every word on point like just so good
i was like oh my god like and i remember
i like i dropped a cue and he was like
oh then you say that and i was just like
oh my god
like i forgot a line
with de niro like like literally like
the shame
and i remember i was like oh my god like
just
like like i was like dude i'm like 36
like this dude's older than me like i
remember i went back to my trailer
and i learned my lines like so
well because i was like there's no way
i'm ever gonna let him like
like remind me of my cue ever again
so he just looked and he goes yeah you
missed the line about
this and then you say that in there and
i was like oh my oh my god
like it was such a i don't know i mean
he's so good it's crazy he's he's really
good
well i ready and yeah go ahead and even
even with like tarantino
i was like i don't think i've ever been
more nervous
around anybody than around clinton
what's his personality like i mean is it
like you see on the daily
yeah oh that's him we're gonna do this
this is gonna be great he's basically
quentin i mean he's always quit
but i was just i was such
like a following devoted fan of his
forever that i'm just i was just like
it was like having like a cult leader
around or something i was just like
you know i don't know it's like i grew
up watching his movies
so much that you know it's like
i just can't i i tried to treat him like
regular or just be calm around but i
just
i couldn't you couldn't you were all
other people i think could but i just
i couldn't do it what kind of direction
did he give you i mean do you remember a
specific direction or like the way he
was acting that
was it was it was he very helpful did he
know exactly what he wanted
yeah i mean i remember early on we did a
read-through
and i was kind of playing j sebring
more as like what i would see in little
video clips of him where he's sort of
like a kind of a calm
kind of like mechanic dower guy
and i sort of so i sort of did that in
the read-through
uh where it was like brad and leo and
burt reynolds at the time it was like
all these crazy awesome margo and dakota
fanning
um and he called me afterwards and he
was like
you know he basically gently told me
that i was
on the wrong path so he basically was
like
i'm this guy this isn't a biopic
he's like you can have fun with the
lines this is this is like this is
tarantino dialogue you can
you can i'm giving you permission to be
more flamboyant
he was like jay isn't gay he's not gay
but he's a flamboyant guy
he's like you can bring that side of
yourself um
he's like i'm giving you permission to
have fun to enjoy it to be more
flamboyant
and as soon as he told me that he really
kind of i was like i went back
and i read the scenes the way that i had
played them
in the read-through and i was like oh my
god like what did i do because i
i totally as soon as he told me that i
completely understood
what he wanted and what he meant in
every line made
sense that way but i was trying to like
kind of fit a square peg into a round
hole
because i was taking these preconceived
notions of what i thought jc sebring was
exactly like based off some video
interview
and you know sometimes in order to kind
of get to the truth of a scene the way
it's written
you need to like not adhere perfectly to
your
preconceived notions of what it should
be yeah well a lot of times you hear
these horror stories and it's it's
happened
it hasn't happened to me but it's
happened to some friends who are
famous that they'll do a table read and
they just for some reason the producer
and the director is like
no this guy's [ __ ] completely off and
they just fire him
yeah i mean you know it was nice enough
for him to call you be like no you could
do this i just know what you're doing
you're playing it more like a biopic you
need to play it
like have fun man i remember when i
first got that call
i i was like oh my gosh like i like
literally was driving and i like
pulled the car over i was like
like waiting for the bomb to drop and i
was like